so you probably heard that old adage
that every person has at least one good
book in them I believe in something
grander than that I believe that every
great person has at least one great beer
all they need is a fearless brewer like
me to coax it out welcome so that's odd
let's drink it today I'm the luckiest
guy in the lower Eastside
I'm at Freeman's I'm meeting with a
young MC named Mac Miller who's been
thinking a lot about his legacy lately
and I brewed a really special beer for
him hopefully one that'll remind him
that whether its beer hip hop some
things do get better with age
so Matt thank you making time we've been
on tour thanks for coming up here for
you sir I've been listening on your
music a lot some common themes seem to
be coming up for me you love your
whiskey a Miami whiskey drinker not
respect whiskey for me is like it always
takes the same journey
it starts intelligent and then it ends
in like sitting by yourself depression
the depression part is great though
you're just like you're just like
sitting in a corner with like a glass
and a cigarette like I hate everybody
here so I'm hoping that what we've made
for you today is gonna just stay in the
in the in the happy moments of the
experience whoo man you know so I brewed
you something really really special on
try this hell yeah
I drew this just for you a whiskey
infused beer hold it up next a little
light notice how it's opaque and kind of
chalky looking yeah that's because it's
been agent in wood for a while so the
fibers of the wood and the yeast it's
not filtered it's rye so how is it not
bubbly so the farting of co2 is what
creates the bubbles in alcohol okay with
this one it's such a big viscous syrupy
beer that the co2 just doesn't really
stay in solution yeah supposed to be a
big foamy beer this is like it's like a
it's really unique when you brew a 12
percent alcohol beer it's way way
outside of it know about the process
normal beer making process plate a lot
of different yeasts to drink more like a
whiskey so presentation wise we want to
serve it in a snifter cuz shape of the
glass lets you smell it warns yeah
straight side deer glass and you're
reminding yourself that is strong and
you don't need a ton of it you know
normal beers about five hours very good
is it don't sound surprised you know
usually when people make me things is
shitty this is good normal a all takes
about two or three weeks to make this
thing spent 45 days in stainless 45 days
in this dark Palo Santo wood and then I
got these whiskey barrels from
tucky and stuck them in there for about
three months for this beer that's
awesome
traditionally American distilleries aged
whiskey and wine inside oak barrels and
over time the barrels leach the spirit
into the wood what is left behind is
what I as a brewer loved to play with
from axe beer we brewed a roasty malty
brown ale and we put it into town branch
bourbon barrels so the smoky white
American oak and delicious layers of
whiskey leached into the beer over time
what would you call this this thing
growler so rouler 1/2 gallon jug holy
[ __ ] right
all the old taverns back in the day when
we were write the Declaration of
Independence in that colonial era a
brewery was in every village of every
town and the same way your mom would go
to the butcher the bakery they would
stop and get your jug of beer and the
dad to get his jug refilled with yell at
the kids go refill my jug of beer and
you growl at the kids
oh never didn't feel feel my growler
you're very well versed you're gonna
have to drink a little bit more this is
yeah true serum and I got some more
questions yeah man so laughter I didn't
make the basketball team I just move you
do like I don't know you're gonna miss
key move it I just figured I made my dad
start loving me then you got a great
line in one of your songs about life's
not worth living unless you're taking
risk
yeah yeah into matches yeah you're
pretty self reflective dude for a guy
your age to see you really start
thinking about the future while you're
looking backwards is pretty amazing
thank you
how do you describe this compare
daughter I think it is it's it's more of
like a questioning things album I think
the last album there were all these
names like this kid with all these
questions and then this person on this
album seems to be a bit more sure of
himself
yeah do you remember like the first hip
hop song you heard on the radio like
holy [ __ ] let me think
I have a stink memory of getting a
Clementine
outcast and locking myself in my grandma
vroom and she had a CD player then that
took out the lyric booklet and I wrapped
along to everything yeah I feel like
that is the reason I am what I am today
because those are some [ __ ] these not
easy to write he's fast as well yeah man
those two guys are [ __ ] yeah hey yeah
how did you get started making beer I
was a home brewer living in New York
City waiting tables and started drinking
beers like shimei red that's like damn I
love beer this is what I want to do my
life when you were like I'm gonna make
beer for a living were they were people
like get a real job yeah my mom and dad
they're like how's your education going
like good except I think I want to be a
brewer you know when I was younger I was
like mister never finish a beer living
in New York like I feel a little more
mature with my drinking yeah cuz it's
really volume its quality right sorry
it's not all about getting hammered
maybe I just want a beer because I like
it and this beer right here though I'm
drinking is [ __ ] delicious it's
really good you have to name this beer
by the way by the end of the day perhaps
the federal government would allow us to
call it [ __ ] delicious rather than
what yeah yeah really like no I love the
beer actually
and to be honest like I was preparing
myself like just in case to be like I've
got really bad diarrhea I'm out of here
no no not even like that but you know
it's like it's like I'm I'm happy that
when it the immediate reaction was like
[ __ ] yeah I have to fake like in it not
know if I just didn't have to like think
like well I don't know is this the beer
I want to give to the world yeah but I
was just like [ __ ] yeah I'm in this is
perfect I like hearing that
yeah dude it's delicious now that I know
Mac digs the 90 day aged beer I made for
him I've got the granddaddy of all aged
beers to sample a vintage 1986 Thomas
Hart this single bottle of beer is
valued at about 150 bucks a pot so this
is like exhibit a of a beer that's
started its journey right and this is
Exhibit B of like a beer that's kind of
good time on a multi-decade
yeah journey this beer when it goes in
the vial is not this
but over time it gets his dark I feel
like you got more than me can I have a
little bit you're a man that's so cool
is that weird yeah dude okay
stingy with it be Jesus Christ see this
unfair oh wow different huh yeah I would
have this with the creme brûlée dessert
in fact actually grab this we put out
some of this try this oh we're gonna go
a segue choices this is a peppery chili
infused chocolate and so the dark green
in the beer we brewed for you and this
is actually gonna be great like foil for
sweet that roastiness should go well is
it basic art see it like if I if I had
friends to impress outpoured it's like
do I like this or is it just no no it's
good but it's intense all right so I'm
definitely keeping my day job as a
brewer but I got to tell you something
you want to be a porn star no I may be
but I also moonlight a little bit I have
the best beer geek hip hop band of my
generation and I want you to see this
and just boom visceral fast reactions
till you tell me I will be honest people
play with their music I'm always honest
so this is a song called pinching
pennies when you can't we're starting
out as a brewer you can't afford new
brewing equipment you got to keep
pension pennies off top I'm gonna say
that I respect you telling your story
thank you my friend you gotta keep
pinching pennies man you gotta shop it
around today's little bit you can't work
to really high budget so far Thanks whoa
fisheye lens actually tired you know I'm
pinching pennies even though I don't
come any I was born in New York not New
Guinea I got enough okay it's the moment
of truth um will Matt Miller like my
rhymes and beads so or did I just not
give him enough delicious beer for him
to live um I know you said you always
beyond I
visually us I'm failing shot
conceptually I didn't really feel the
struggle of a brewer trying to make it
work on probably just where's Miguel
okay
I gotta work on being the better being
like a good rapper what's on your mind
chanting in this beer name that's right
you still have to do that we say okay so
12 what was it what personnel Co 12
personnel Goldie 50/50 what
International bittering unit type where
if we called 1250 1250 like with a slash
like it's a time right so 12 boom 50 we
did that okay
Oh baby week 50 IBUs the beer is 12 -
hey guys that hole you got a name we
don't have to ask them it's not just
[ __ ] a me yeah 12 is not here B let's
call 1250 call the green 450 yeah
well done that was a fun little sesh
right